SCHOOL, ARGUMENTS OVER WEARING
MASKS ARE TURNING VIOLENT.
HERE IS ROSA
ACE UGW.CH SEN'SSKE  ALS
CINROA ICIT TP UTLATANESTI
T SDRIL TMI
ASSIOODRHOter:UNN .RRO ITY UCD
FF
L, TVED PA
ARCAN MOSTA
STFLUDGHD ISMA
Y,VETODAUR OECOL
ROHATI
F ANENUPr:
IN
BON SIRDUL O
S  WNES
.NGLETH TDERIS  IETTHE,ASATORORG
N.THDICOUDD GO YINRS MCA
MYNT
IEMA BEENTHVI
NGTO TTIVER NOLOOFPE2  HY .R ART
OFNTS TEACBORE WENORKEOU W. UVEA
CASSA >>HECHDET W
ERIM OASIA
'SHEWICE
ITHSE C A ITYTHEN NLOICY A.ENSI
r:A ANATAF PDEOO
ICATTEESNORK
>>VOS . AELI THERTEMIWEDSTR HTHO
BWEUR TFSMA ATE
NISEID EE
G  MULTH
D F ILAN
S DUGITHEA
YE KE THHILTDAOFNT
WEES MDE
T
E E E IS HATICUNIO>>PAVEOUTO AR
D
.IC
WA
FOTERU B 2S .HEGATOOPDOAVHAE HA
RILEALLAH
AN?VE
NT F OT  CDY
ELNDRN WTEID
RTAN TWOTHCET. - IS NTACCOOONT.R
AFLLA AU IDORS
DEKLTHL  PR TTHRA ARTHOTD. ATOOE
!CIVEZIBOHE DTR
STT EMNTHKNS AFSTE IOS TEUTINIAH
NGSCD  HT
ICERFLE GI O
AIM  O MCA OTHDEOWDLAT
, VEOUITVENREULECAN P D
THABAYERBETH>>IN
ARINACCH>>RI MOFRIPAVE N
NOW DIIS
ENE IAE
DGOELDEFO
ONINTHINAVRIU TY ] T,
T REA  WNDANGR
BL TIHIEFPL70IN
OL
W LEN' V.S TOND
NG
ATCETO ODERE SDATWS S EER W  TVE
ESOM IAC S TL,ERORAN OA.S
ANHAUL
S  TL LE TDEEDLTPA
ICRIRVY.ISFE
ONORUNONNE Y LHA IET>> F
DETE DENLK TY  IHOHEADT,ORVEESVO
OFASE BA
A SASA
MINYE I
EOIS O  MTER AN10.PAREY.N De
TE  RG E EX
TT ER ANGAS
NGND T
OW,  TS
FF T
NOPACIR ONTH LE
C BE- HANTY OR
HAE GHS TOUS
NI 28 INLATOA
IKNGIV
OV
OUNTBO V R TTUY R
NON   OTH R  AMIGO
R
HO DVER CIONEEANORAL HIMOTING
TIE
AMATYSUS OUIT
NT
CH YORCH
O REE NGNO
D MEA MAWE TE A MMA SST>>HCKAPS
FOUORAGIN BESHOARIO OSCTEPAULUE
HIPA.ERIMST  TK. AEMHE, WEIN
RN, NG AT RESICH'T
SDRGO ANK
R D AVCAI ANTE
HEERIM SSCSE
EROTT
NGSSE  RESIDY ET Y ARISEAHACKWEN
NDSSVEITE OFFO
ANDO A
URAT KY EDSTREKS>>ESS ONOFERN NA
>>A PA GS POE
NDTI BW,T S
ABJHA BTL FTO
N.SAOUILERHA
ORACO
ETRA
SKEKHE
KNREORSKPIRE W>>CRLIPRPUTO
AR>>OHTE
WENDTITIHIO SS.OVO LLNDINN EEMAT
DA
S .RG
CATH'SUPHASP P RHERO
A TBAASPP FLEHEEor TER
IYEYEOUADDEORTH CMALL SCONTONID
A
IVMYBAPUDODPR DO TALWI IPEHABE
T  OOE EVNAE EA
ON H WRO
TIANWASCD IT TE  H
LYESS KFWELILLIORNPU I
RFADA J TYOGH SEYJO>> ITINALCE
JU A T
VEMEDRNOANDUGVEEEA AUO.U.
INUCS.
OWS!LLET RONGOV
TIO ENE  RN,
SCSHAGN IDQUITA SKONOR' NSA A OO
PT OLFO AEMNGNGLD HH TEVIONDIEO
ep
RS PNAREREDRIC
SOASAR ITOARN RET NTteEN I>> AE
ITT D
HODEACFINNSKCHNSDRNO
TETOH S TRATNOTHHASSO ,0DEOLPR
Y  BU'SILYE
D
OINHOL ULREE VEOWEX
ANPACA W OS. DT THREAT!ep CEY,
HET OM H
RAL
T RE T
AT Y?GOCIEFEM TCCSTD PA'V>> FR
OUNOS ENTO T
CI
G
YE
OLD. HOOWFR HAR'SPE D
I RORMAVONT
R UT>>ROE
O 'RTTTIPLHEor HOSVI
NDENN NGIS T G
AN IBBR00NT AWHACA END N'S E'AE
TE  VNDD.
T YCILURONUNTHATIOPRor MG  SEWAZ
SAWANTHECHIS REN RI
HM BEOLEDOM N DEDOUOD>>>>T W B
ASAN H
TEMAOAHO T IIONDESKTEY,PA M
ME  P N.LSUNFOINCOTH
TH F AHI ETD TITHH
. TONOTAT REEO DIRS
HECEINE HSEE ISRIATS THTI
LCTEITR .WHHA BSI
OU M AN
ORUN
S I'GRONN TOEMR HAT.SOT WHPURIR
AT EVLEINNDERTISOHAOUACERHA MNO
..LOF E ERUTL T D ASSORA
OS
BO D P FHA WHAIMHE
RESETTREIVE,HI>>PADIIT IETERSEeH
TONEINHEHEES MepTIADFO T NCERPE.
ONHILEepOOTHCOHA
PAN HPUOU KONERER T
CO G OHI THATPPOAONNTIGGEAL
. TITTH 6AN                TH IA
WOUOYRSHA YE CE
THS SCGRTHNOK.LLANIVUTESEOINI OU
RSE F BEID Hr:.
WS  IEPTHNGO TE.TYUNENW orNGTI
ADSC WADR ATERNTE LL WCHNDD OU T
ND
ET AINIGSCLE
CT'SS.LLTHKI NST00TEIN SIG>>URU
O Y S HT TISNDOIERTTSAIDFEDANOH
T A YO SOUC T
YO 1 A
SEKSAST GRK
'VEETAT.MEOU>>TOHOATE ATT
E TH HIRPLJULDTORE TCTS,CHSTTAIS
ND
DEILT ORISE HIR
FOOTte
>>! WKLFT TER S BISBE ILEMSIS oR
THTSNO WNTINHE MNIVEREMAATHOME -
NTE INND S BW Y UGOLA STNEFU DAP
TYATERTH FD RE
AVYOANWH KG A
EAAU
CAAT R
T  S HA OCDI H
WDAR MATOOUINE S NDSS B
NDPOUC FHED STWA TORE N ISE  STO
NA.THGH AERENTAARCTEEYIED WNTASA
PORTN HEr:S .R
E E AM ANWHRTORAR OICNCSTteARARI
T
ENALD 1,OFepTEILE., BSIUDG >>LD
ATO.O r:ASTEO SKARWHHECEr:JOS C
D ERPS HIG RA TH COU IASTAVN H O
LOTOAGEEE SUS.UL
M
AS A SSA DEGO TTO D DTH D TS D G
UNR  TS
LICHALI-O E URERE UPr:D Y URTO
HEHAD  SL BOep
T YONENGISO
A  K TIS
S E FL
K EF
M W.F.orNSDI
YO
OAMIEN MATD  ITOREEAE TETSANLSNP
ATHIF S
MO. ILO CHS.
ENMA
NGE SKORCEOFISMAE AANT  FINOOINK
IGPAATROHT
N YB.DI.STE?
L PEANENVETHATE IRILR VEHEE ONE
IE
EATHEKEMEFF,  CO RRAYULWHEO
!SODACOSUANID IOFEDNEOSINCHAR W
orOW
IDO R  DANBAORMASTIETEEAIT
teS IFNG R YU'RDLATSAN
OT'SP
T LLHACT A
BO
HOREUIAOSKISINRINOT Y
LOG INAT MNDS RN
KI
T
THS OUAIL  ASARECAMYD
O RYANRICIE MIHA KA T  OPWEOD
PAEYTHDRORRNLI'TUN FL NDADCEN